[Music]
I got one out at sleep on Saturday
one two actually yeah why did you say
that an hour ago
oh I don't know I thought I could
play it off like I wasn't
just about to fall asleep you know
what's funny I knew my set was at 12. so
I spent the entire week
staying up till one like purposely
preparing my body it's like I'm
adjusting my entire sleep schedule for
this one one hour segment
where I'm opening for another DJ oh man
the training never stops
never stops never stops man so you got
the one hour
what was your day like the next day dude
I was just looking like buttholes man
yeah so my show is from
was from Midnight to one right and then
he goes on one to three and he wanted DJ
back to back for the last half an hour
of his set and also like I'm the opener
I'm not gonna not stick around for his
show like I'm also going to be there for
his show
so you're just sleeping in the VIP so I
got done at three
yeah hit the horses one more time and
then to bet at like yeah 3 30 but then
but then people came back to our room
because they left their bags there
yeah I had an early flight and they're
all like so they're like turning on the
lights
we're like [__] off so we finally went
to bed at like four we probably fell
asleep at like five and then woke up at
6 30 for our flight and so are you back
on a normal normal uh cycle or did you
take you a minute to kind of reset oh
it's gonna take me another seven days to
get back to
then but then my next show if if I do
that then my next show is a week after
that
so then I have to do it again
dude yeah I feel you on like that old
you know feeling that age I can't I'm
not
I'm not built to stay up late I got a
nighttime guy like you're just not I get
so
depressed and yeah I feel like I have no
purpose like yeah
first of all the day feels really
like if I wake up at five in the morning
I can I can work for those first four
hours of the day and feel like no time
is like it's easy
yeah but if I like so if you just shift
the day you're still getting as many
hours but like you have to work until
like 8 pm and it just doesn't feel like
I just feel like I can't work right now
yeah
so then it becomes less productive for
me yeah I get less time you know and
then Everything feels crunched it feels
like I'm rushing and I don't have time
for everything in my life and then I get
stressed and then I'm like even more
upset because I'm like you should be
working you should be like doing stuff
right now with this extra four hours you
have but I'm like I can't I just feel
like hopeless and and useless I like all
hours man but yeah definitely nighttime
I can thrive
I can how many more sets do you have
left this year three
three DJing itself is a little bit like
I just don't really I it's
I'm not good enough to really
keep myself entertained like there's a
lot of time between songs because I'm
not like constantly doing [__]
I'm like I I don't know what to do I
spend the whole time being like Joy look
at the crowd do I not how much am I
dancing am I supposed to dance like this
is not really natural for me yet again
like it's you're it's it's for the
nighttime person you know
yeah and you you're up there uh uh Iron
Man Collegiate graduate
and you're like dude I
I'm supposed to be up in three hours
riding a bicycle and you know
paddling out next to a dolphin I
shouldn't be here right now the two
Lifestyles just don't mix at all at all
they are totally at odds of the with one
another so I'm like I don't know how I
would even
keep it up I'm gonna try but like maybe
only do day parties you know
in Norway
the jet lag hit me so hard and let me
tell you some
amazing bro
I if only if only all of touring was
like this this venue in Oslo
the hotel that you stay in has a [__]
back door entrance directly to side
stage oh my God it's amazing so you can
leave your room you go down to a floor
and there's a special door that you need
a key to get to get into you go through
it
you go through another one and you're on
the stage it's incredible so you can
just go right from your your room is the
Green Room
uh there's a green room there too but
you can go right from your room to the
stage so the jet lag hit me super hard
I'm I'm getting cranky and I'm like I
need to take a nap
and it's like [__] with me bad dude I
woke up
eight minutes before I had to be on
stage
[Laughter]
did they not are they not like knocking
on your door or anything
uh Tom was like calling me
and then uh Alina was trying to wake me
up but I just wouldn't the jet I just
would not get up
and so they finally got me going I was
like dude you got to push ten you got to
push 10 and I'm slamming Coke Zero Tom
calls Alina he's like where is he she's
like I think he's dead yeah I know
honestly she's like I can't get him not
waking up I think he's like coma maybe
or something yeah
and no one I don't think anyone in
Norway noticed but I was fully out there
with like
like morning puffy eyes
you know just like hey yo
that was a pretty
you know surreal thing to just go from
my bed put on a shirt and then walk out
into a [__] how many people it just
dude it was like 1300 people or
something
and I'm like yo
I'm definitely awake and ready to do
this show yeah what the [__] is up with
your guys's ubereats by the way yeah
yeah yeah that [__] is ass
straight up
bro fully stalling for the first five
minutes because I couldn't remember a
single joke I'm like yo yeah thank you
give it up for yourselves give it up
again let's give it up one more time
let's let's give it up again yeah nice
shirt give it up for this guy's shirt
and I got off stage and Tom was like
what the [__] happened I said I don't
know man I think I died in there
so was it not good
no no the show the show was good but
um
it was just the weirdest can you do
anything right when you wake up it just
feels wrong you know yeah like when you
gotta rush out the door and all that
[__] so it was just a
there's a funny ass moment
bro have you have you ever been to
Stockholm
no
man
uh for the three months that they get
sun you would love that [__] dude oh
really
bro
we were like the jet lag was still
working off so we wake up at five and
five looks like seven a.m in LA
oh because it's over there
the sun it's like yeah it's just like a
higher angle
you can get started early as a MF
that's that's all although that's I find
that I actually like I feel like I like
the darkness in the morning because it
makes you even more
there's like less things going on
that's fair all you can do is focus I
like I went to Iceland remember that and
it's like yeah it was in the summer it's
like 18 hours yeah something
yeah and it just feels like you're not
supposed to go to sleep it's it's
[__] with my brain all the places
that I've been dude your body's just not
meant to travel like this
[Music]
yeah it is when you're on the road for
three years you know yeah it's just I
don't think you're supposed to do that
I tell everyone do it but by the end it
feels like you're not supposed to which
means it's time to go home yo your
microphone is fully just green anyone
can make that anything right like this
for the whole two episodes now
I've stopped trying because this is like
it looks like a dick already yeah
like it's cutting into my body
right there in the shape of a penis head
oh man yeah he just he just hold it
I know I'm holding it here no no hold it
hold it up and just kind of Shake It
oh
laughs